NARRATOR: But
everyone loves Lucy.
The story of this great white
is the classic "Finding Nemo"
tale, but about
2,000 pounds heavier.
When divers spotted
Lucy back in 2008,
her distinctive tail
wound looked fresh.
And she seemed in desperate
need of a good meal.
A damaged caudal often puts
a shark's life in danger.
It's crucial for propelling
a shark through water.
APRYL BOYLE: Lucy's
its tail deformity
could be from fighting
with another shark
when she was younger.
NARRATOR: And Lucy's not
only survived, she's thrived.
She did it by modifying the way
she swims to sway a little more
than the average great white.
And now Lucy's
adoring public keeps
an eye out for her
signature floppy fin
and her unique swagger.
Unlike other
female great whites,
Lucy returns to Guadalupe
Island every year.
And that is because she
has not given birth yet.
If she did, she'd be gone
at least 12 to 18 months,
because that's how long
a shark pregnancy lasts.
NARRATOR: Fans
don't know for sure
why Lucy is still not a mom.
It could be that male
sharks are turned
off by her misshapen fin.
Or maybe Lucy hasn't
yet met Zapata,
the most famous and
recognizable male great white
of Guadalupe Island.
This tough guy is a
14-footer, who has mixed it up
with other apex
predators and has
the battle scars to prove it.
RALPH COLLIER: Zapata
is a very large shark.
To sustain the
wounds it received,
the attacking shark must have
been very large, possibly
18 or 20 feet in length.
NARRATOR: He might not play
well with other sharks.
But luckily, unlike
Bullet, Zapata actually
enjoys hanging out with people.
That's my favorite
shark right there, Zapata.
NARRATOR: Scarboard, at an
intimidating 18 feet long,
isn't just one of the
most massive sharks
at Guadalupe Island,
she's one of the biggest
great whites in the world.
But like all sharks, no one
will know for sure how old
she is until after she dies.
RALPH COLLIER: One of the ways
to determine the age of a shark
is by dissecting it.
If we cut through
a vertebra, we can
see rings similar to those of
a tree showing annual growth.
She got her
nautically themed name
because of scars on the right,
or starboard, side of her body.
APRYL BOYLE: When sharks
engage in head-to-head combat,
they can do incredible
damage to each other, which
is what happened to Scarboard.
But sharks have amazing
healing abilities.
NARRATOR: Scarboard shows up
at Guadalupe every other year.
And the next time you see
her, many of her scars
might be gone.
Bullet, Lucy, Zapata,
and Scarboard,
four sharks whose physical
flaws grabbed our attention.
and helped make them famous.